This is exactly my point. At the time,
she had millions of followers,
and I was a very small creator,
and I very much kind of treated TikTok like my online journal.
And this was just friends that I talked to.
And that video was the turning point.
It was the first time that I went, like,
viral, viral.
And I did not understand the hate that could come.
I was like, what?
I'm just a fucking mom on TikTok,
like, talking to my friends.
Why are people coming for me?
And I literally. It fucking set me on a fucking mental spiral for, like,
eight months
because I had felt so misunderstood and so judged and so hurt.
And I really. I guess I just didn't fully understand
that's how the internet works is,
you know. I mean,
now I get it. The hate is what gets you going.
So who gives a fuck? People are good.
Plenty. People got plenty opinions about me.
I don't care now.
But that was one of those fucking moments that turned it for me.
And I just cannot get out of my head
that I think she's a shitty person
because of it. She could have sent me a DM.
There were other large creators that got tagged in the video that were
like, yo,
check this out. They cleared it up and did not come for me.
Matter of fact,
mental illness has done me so many fuckings that he has Like,
stitched my videos multiple times.
He has shared his platform with me so many times to try to, like,
you know, just give me a boost a little bit.
Like, you could tell he's just trying to help me out a little bit.
He could see that the internet came for me hard,
and it was very undeserved.
And little bitch Mama's Hot was one of the main ones,
and I fucking cannot stand her.
She didn't take, you know,
she didn't use her shit responsibly.